e aí
e se esta esta é nossa ps4 lego olá
pessoal aqui quem fala é aqui sejam
muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo aqui tá
priminho que coisa fofa do que deixa eu
gravar o vídeo até lá
o principal tá possuído e como estava a
dizer olá tudo pessoal daqui fala aqui
sejam muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo e
como é que eles estão passar a
quarentena por favor eu estou mais ficar
em casa só para começar aqui o vídeo não
é porque eu não ando com mais tá em casa
tá difícil não tenho passado muito mas
muito tempo em casa eu estou a tentar
cumprir assim arrisca a quarentena ok
temos em poucas vezes de casa só para ir
comprar a comida e medicamentos então
como vocês já puderam vir pelo título ou
hoje nós vamos meu vamos fazer uma coisa
insana que eu já quero fazer a muito
tempo mas nunca tive coragem porque
tenho medo de estragar a minha
playstation 4 mas já que vai sair a
playstation 5 e eu certamente vou
comprar eu vou riscar customizar a minha
playstation 4 hoje vamos fazer um erro
banho e o que ela não sei que estão
tenho madrugada eu tive essa ideia e
montei aqui o projeto em photoshop meu
se sair como ficou no photoshop eu acho
que vai ficar incrivelmente fixe mas
vamos lá ver o que faz isso aqui eu vou
demonstrar primeiramente aqueles mostrar
aqui o que eu já tenho pena
oi oi
eu já deixei que irá playstation no
quarto tem um erro dar que tu és burro
idiota é que a minha playstation 4 super
funcional espero que continuo e tenho
aqui também todos os acessórios da lego
que eu preciso para fazer aqui o projeto
eu quero dar aquele ar assim mais 20 diz
mais retro então vamos fazer em lego
quero cobriu toda de lego como é que
está pezinhos que eu tinha cá em casa
que tinha sobrado suas campanhas que fiz
então que eu tinha aqui esse material em
vez de deitar fora vamos utilizar estes
são os tapetes de led que eu vou
precisar são precisamente estas nas
cores preto azul verde azul escuro
vermelho esta cor aqui eu não vou
utilizar eu vou pintar de amarelo eu já
vou mostrar o projeto que sair como sair
uma photoshop meus amigos meus caros
inscritos vai ficar incrível melhor do
que a playstation 5 talvez não isso não
isso nunca na vida meu vocês já viram os
gráficos do playstation sem tão
incrivelmente absurdos tipo parece filme
preparem porque passa estupidamente
bonita ó olha só três eu quero a minha
consola assim como está aqui os recordes
aqui a verde o logo da playstation
o clássico jogo de playstation um todo o
resto por dentro vai ficar preto dark
como é que tu fizeste isso daqui como é
que tu custa cristo logo da playstation
assim tão bem ah pois é meus amigos e
dar a consciência isso também matemática
eu tive que fazer uns cálculos eu tenho
aqui outro projeto aqui um construir
todo logo da playstation pois sabia que
és podre tem como base e tentei
construir aquilo logo mais ou menos
parecido ao de playstation no vamos ver
se tu vai dar certo pessoal desde já
inscrevam aqui no canal deixem muito
like aqui nesse vídeo se vocês tiverem
playstation 4 terá que fazer também se
ficar bom vamos ver se vai ficar bom
claro né ficar podre não façam eu até
recomendo que não faço eu estou aqui de
estar ok eu não sou dono da verdade eu
não sou método dos dias iguais menos um
estar aqui fazer alguma coisa de jeito
mas para vai ser proibida pessoal deixem
muito like porque não comigo e bora lá ó
o playstation tá cheio de volta talvez
preciso limpar mas agora este é o passo
mais importante que como começar este
projeto não faço ideia então para estar
certo eu acho que cima de vamos recortar
todas as peças de lego para construir o
logo da playstation e não vamos colar
vamos só recortar o que é
e aí
oi ok ok já montei aqui parte vermelho é
como podem ver fica bem louco eu não
pensei que fosse tão fácil recortar mas
também ó tenho aqui o açúcar e misture
olha aí essa mistura e poderoso tá
desfocada vamos lá montar o resto é
eu esqueci a minha parte do pessimista
eu acho que esse projeto vai dar sem
poder 300 certa correta no bem não sei
quem é
eu vim aqui está pessoal nosso logotipo
da playstation montado meu funcionou
perfeitamente bem agora faça um passo
antes de colar vamos pintar essas peças
com amarelo para ver se eu tenho aqui
algumas pintas amarelas eu não sei se
esta é mais indicada por que esta diz
que é para interior ea brilhante eu não
sei se o brilhante o mais certo para
pintar aquele plástico então vamos ver
se eu tenho aqui outra só que esta é a
base de água também acho que não é
interessante e tem outra aqui essa
também graça e também com água não ok a
melhor tinta destas três eu acho que
esta e apesar de ser brilhante eu acho
que é que está com melhor aspecto então
vamos usar esta aqui me ajuda antes a
minha ajudante de linda daqui
a última peças né eu não sabia o que era
mas foi tu pediste então
e aí chega negócio que ter só preciso
nesse caso aqui o cartão se não
conseguir arrancar errado acho que eram
então é pa ela fazer o adiciona ok acho
que eu nem sei se esta lata está a
funcionar mas vamos ver
o que pode as peças ficaram amarelas mas
eu não sei se vocês conseguem reparar
aqui que por cima destes relevos fica
uma bolha de tinta e eu não sei se isso
vai interferir depois com a montagem ou
se vai ficar feio quando está aqui assim
maior eu não sei vamos esperar secar e
vamos ver como vai ficar
o esporte é assim que eu treino zouk
apanhar os ladrões e
e não não
o que é que se passa contigo eu aposto
no tudo posto ladrão não sabe o que
gosta de fazer conta de luz parece
parece um bojo vamos primeiro o primeiro
antes de tudo vou colocar um rebordo já
com a fita verde porque assim não é
engano a hipótese de haver engano não é
porque já tem um seguro feito depois aí
sim vou colocar o logo vou colar depois
da fita amarela secar e é assim por
último vou colocar então a fita preta
para preencher os vazios mas primeiro
vamos colocar o verbo
e aí
e vejam só como ficou esse rebordo verde
primeiro tá muito perto tá muito cheio
trocar incrível aí digam aqui não está
muito bom olha aí ok tem que ter algumas
pequenas falhas e tal mas eu acho que
até fica bonito assim tipo estas
aberturas assim tá lá tem que nível
adorei espero que os três consigam
passar aqui na mesma espero que sim
jogos e tudo mais tem aqui algumas
formas e depois eu vou levar ó é
incrível está com eu queria eu até
disney aqui esta linha de ver também
inicialmente é só para ficar aqui o
retângulo a volta mas eu achei que
ficava muito bonito então fica assim
mesmo temos que ver como vai ficar a
e aí
e como esperava aqui uma coisa que eu
não gostei que é as peças com a tinta
amarela que aumenta a tinta começou a
faltar porque a base de silicone então
por último passo eu acho que um verniz
vai resolver ok e
e aí
e nem sei quanto tempo eu fiquei aqui
mas demorou imenso tempo ajustar as
peças porque aconteceu aquilo que eu
tinha em toda a pedro que não foi bem
cortado ficou um pouco para fora então
tive que ajustar as peças todas tive que
ajustar tudo os cortes tive de dar
imensos menos mas eu digo uma coisa
ficou espetacular a nossa ps4 de esta
esta é a nossa ps4 de uai lego o que
vocês acharam pessoas em casa façam
porque eu estou vivo eu não sei se aí tá
aparecer tão bom como está aqui na
realidade meu mas o filme o toque que
ela tem que tá mesmo brutal eu vou agora
colocar ali no nosso cenário onde eu
costumo terá ps4 mas ela tá um pouco
escondida ali atrás e agora vou tentar
arranjar um suporte para ela assim que
demais nos vistas né tipo pessoal que
entrar aqui no estúdio
e logo aparece 4 assim que tá muito bom
tão linda eu nem tava aí para ficar
assim então fiz temos aqui o nosso
resultado pessoal ficou sem por cento
igual ao photoshop está incrível espero
que vocês tenham gostado e vamos só
espero que vocês tenham gostado aqui
deste vídeo deu imenso trabalho eu
preciso mesmo muito vosso like e
partilhem comigo se eu tiver playstation
4 enviem ele vai se relacionar com
certeza meu quem é que não gostava de
ter uma proteção 4 assim não é porque
foi eu que fiz mas estava muito bonita
mesmo volta a faca mas é isso pessoal
espero que tenham gostado já sabem se
quiserem ver mais vídeos de yu hai eu
faço uma série ok e é isso fica bem até
a próxima então tá bem pessoal aqui
embaixo vocês também tem outros vídeos
podem existir tem que investir tem que
ir eu não sei bem à disposição mas estão
aqui entre as pessoas estão tenho
certeza que vão gostar e é isso tchau
tchau
[Música]